Okay Google, what would
we learn? Hello world,
it's Siraj and 2018 will be the year.
We finally start to see
chat bots go mainstream.
In this video we'll build a chat bot
using Google's tensorflow machine learning
framework. If you've created
an awesome product or service,
you've got to find a way to get it
out there for people to see it. Right?
Content marketing is the
process of creating an organic
growth channel for your
business using content. This
could be blog posts, videos,
infographics who had prank videos,
content that can help attract
thousands of potential customers,
and since content creation is itself
a very time consuming process,
we need to make sure we're delivering
it in the most efficient way possible.
The ability to gain insights from
user behavior via machine learning
technologies has completely
changed the marketing game.
Now companies can interpret exactly what
their customers are like and what they
do on the Internet. Email inboxes
have become more and more cluttered,
so buyers have moved to social media
to follow the brands they really care
about.
Smart brands have moved from email
marketing to social media marketing to
interact with and engage their
customers to maximize sales.
Most people stick to using just five
apps and today messaging apps have over 5
billion monthly active users,
which means that for the first time
people are using them more than social
networks.
It's fair to say users are spending
more time on whatsapp and messenger than
they do on Twitter and Facebook.
That's because chatting is more
of an engaging activity. Lol, Lma,
Mayo,
rof l brands need to start engaging
their customers through these messaging.
Mediums and chatbots are the solution
chatbots or a type of program that
converse with a user.
They mimic humans both in conversational
ability and in performing any task.
Alan terrain,
one of the fathers of computer science
burst spoke of the concept in the fifties
and since then the concept of a chat
Bot has evolved through the decades.
They're gaining popularity in the
implementation of real world applications
since they can cater the customer
experience by providing engaging support,
product recommendations and
conversational marketing campaigns.
They never sleep, they're cost efficient
and they work well enough to increase.
All sorts of metrics from clickthrough
rates to customer sentiment.
They can function as a support
agent, a lawyer, teacher, doctor toy,
or even as a companion that enriches
your life. Domino's pizza for example,
created a chat Bot for Facebook messenger
where users can order delivery through
their chat Bot and get status
updates on the delivery. Nick Dutch,
the marketing lead at the company admitted
that it didn't necessarily translate
to a huge surge in sales,
but it did result in an improvement
in experience and as a result,
sentiment towards the brand consulting
groups like bought works.ai or using AI
to create chatbots for brands like
change.org Tony Robbins and media posts to
help them engage consumers across
a wide variety of platforms,
tailoring the technology to
each brands specific needs.
There are also tons of services that led
companies build chatbots for their own
needs like Amazon, Lex, Ibm Watson,
a zero bought services and motion.ai.
Clearly the tools and interest are there,
but how are we supposed to,
to choose what tools we need
to build our own chat bot,
brush and relay anyone we can easily use.
A service that lets us set a few rules
and deploy our own chat Bot in a few
minutes,
but rather than just doing that,
let's talk about how this
all works under the hood.
Technically there are two major
types of dialogue systems,
goal oriented ones and
general conversation ones.
General conversation models
can be divided into two types,
generative and selective models.
The idea is the same for both.
We'll input some dialogue and it will
predict the answer for that context.
I mean all of machine learning follows
the same basic steps for a model,
build it, train it and test
it, but before we even do that,
we need to find some
quality dialogue data.
What we need is a dialogue dataset and
since labeled datasets are easiest to
learn from,
we'd want that.
We'd call each row in it
a context replied pair.
The context could be
one or several inputs,
sentences and the reply will be to label.
Sometimes there is an eos or end of
sequence token at the end of each sentence
in the batch.
This helps machine learning algorithms
understand sentence bounds and update its
internal states wisely.
We can find this dialogue
dataset on various websites,
support calls that were recorded,
movie dialogues, rap battles.
All of these are real human
conversations that our AI can learn from.
Let's start with generative models. One
of my favorite machine learning papers,
a neuro conversational model tackle this
problem head on a couple of years ago.
They use a model called
sequence to sequence to model
the dialogue given to them
in a Dataset.
This model is represented by two recurrent
neural networks with a different set
of parameters each while
regular feed forward.
Neural networks are given a new data point
at every time step during training to
learn from recurrent neural networks
are given both a new data points and the
learned hidden states from the previous
time step at each new time step during
training. In this way, there is a
recurrence in what it's learning.
It's learning not just from the data.
It's the learning from how it's learned
to before a sort of recurrence or a
feedback loop. Loopity loop, Scoop d dupe.
This is really useful for learning from
sequences of data where predicting the
next word in a sequence depends
not just on the previous words,
but all the words that came before it.
The first recurrent net
is called the encoder.
It's given a sequence of context tokens,
one at a time and updates it's
hidden state. Accordingly.
After processing the
whole context sequence,
it produces a final hidden state which
incorporates the context and uses it for
generating the answer.
The other recurring net
is called the decoder.
It's job is to take the
context representation from
the encoder as input and
output. An answer. The reply
generation process works like this.
The decoders hidden state is initialized
using the final hidden state from the
encoder. The Eos token is the
first input to the decoder,
which updates it's hidden state.
A word is sampled from the last layer.
It's fed in as input. The hidden state
is updated and a new word is output.
This process is repeated in a loop
until an eos token is output or some
predefined maximum answer
length threshold is hit.
This process is considered inference.
It's the process that a chat bot model
goes through in real time once it's
already been trained.
The training part works slightly
differently in each decoding step.
We use the correct word instead
of the generated one as the input.
Basically the decoder consumes
a correct reply sequence,
but with the last token removed
and the Eos token pretended.
The goal during training is to maximize
the probability of the correct next word
on each time step.
We're asking the network to predict
the next word in the sequence.
By providing it with a correct prefix.
We minimize the error through the most
popular optimization strategy in machine
learning backpropagation,
which I of course have a
five minute video on swag.
See the link in the video description.
This type of model worked pretty well,
but it still had some generic
responses like okay, or I don't know.
Another major problem was
that it generated inconsistent
responses like asking
the same question twice and
getting two different answers.
A newer paper that
dealt with these issues,
what's called a persona based
neuro conversational model.
The authors used speaker ids for each
utterance in order to generate an answer
which learned not based only on the
encoder state but also on speaker
embeddings.
When it comes to selective models,
instead of estimating the probability
of a certain reply given a certain
context,
they learn a similarity function where
a reply is one of the elements in a
predefined pool of possible
answers the network.
We'll take context and a possible
reply as inputs and we'll return the
confidence of how appropriate they are
to each other to neural networks can be
used here and they can
be of any given type.
The first network is used for the
context and the second one for the reply.
These networks will take it's input and
embed them into a vector representation.
Then the similarity between the context
and replied vector is computed using
cosign similarity.
During inference,
we can simply calculate the similarity
between a given context and all possible
answers to choose the one
with the maximum similarity.
In order to train the model,
we'll use triplet loss,
which includes the context,
the correct reply and the wrong reply.
By minimizing this loss.
We learned the similarity function in a
ranking way where absolute values aren't
informative,
so which type of model should we use?
Generative models can generate
almost any type of answer,
but the con is that it's difficult to
impose certain properties on model replies
like no curse words or speak
like a certain character.
Selective models have a more
restricted pool of answers,
but they are more customizable.
The best way to evaluate a chat bot
is through human evaluation currently,
but as research progresses, we'll come
to a more systematic approach here.
Despite a lot of work in this area,
neural dialogue systems are not ready to
talk with humans in an open domain and
give them helpful answers,
but close domain applications like
technical support are a perfect fit.
Three things to remember from this video.
More people are using messaging apps,
then social media apps
in this day and age,
which offers a huge opportunity for
brands to engage their customers through
chatbots.
Chatbots can follow either a
generative or selective process.
Both involve neural networks and there
are a ton of services that will help you
build chatbots,
each with varying degrees of control.
Links to some in the video description.
Are you pumped to build a chat by yet?
You should be subscribe for more
gems like this. And for now,
I'm going to engage my audience,
so thanks for watching.